hey welcome to a new project camp update
so we bought this big piece of land and
a prototyping a more sustainable way of
living
not sure how it's going to go but let's
see and in the previous update you could
see the shipping container arriving to
the land so we installed it
and we also cleaned up the space around
it to make the place a bit nicer
and in this video i'm going to show you
our biggest problems or
challenges and one of the big problems
we have right now
is that we normally have a place to sit
[Music]
[Applause]
so
[Music]
so that was an easy problem okay so
talking about problems
so i already made one of these videos
before and update number eight
all right so here are our challenges and
i had three problems we had back then
one was we needed the roads to be
cleaned so the container could arrive
check we needed to get an address to
make sure we could ask for quotations
for electricity
check and we actually need to get
electricity we're not there yet
we did ask for quotations and it would
be twenty thousand euro two hookers up
to the grid
um because then we get our own
transformator and we can distribute from
there
for half the price ten thousand euro the
electricity company would pay half
so uh yeah we split the cost but it also
means then it's public
so anyone else around you could use it
meaning you might end up in the future
having electricity pulls on your land
or the third alternative is still to go
completely
off grid i'm not really sure yet what to
do with the grid situation
so for now we decided to just have a
small solar setup just to power base
camp
and we're going to use a generator if we
ever need to use
our three-phase electricity which would
be very occasionally just for chopping
something every now and then
but that's going to be it for quite a
while actually and then later on once we
really built the workspace we're going
to see whether we're going to put it
full of panels or we're going to
hook to the grid so yeah those problems
are kind of fixed i would say
another thing we're going to have coming
up is the water
so we need to get water to hook up these
containers
still looking a bit into what makes
sense can we realistically clean
our natural springs how long does it
take do we need to drill a borehole
yeah we're still looking into that but
to be honest these are not really
problems
maybe challenges but not even that it's
kind of straightforward
because it just takes some investigation
you know it's possible and then she
would come up with a solution
but i would say we actually have one way
bigger problem
one uh i don't know
okay let's dive into this
so the problem my mind is not very clear
on this so i hope it comes out a bit
fluent and i also was doubting a lot
actually whether i should mention
because once you hear
you cannot unhear so it might affect
those who actually gonna come to project
camp
and they would focus on it but anyway
the problem is
highway sounds yes i know sounds very
boring but kind of a big deal
so in general this is quite a peaceful
and quiet place and a few weeks ago we
started hearing
highway sounds we're not really sure why
they were suddenly there
maybe the neighbor chopped down some
trees
and suddenly the sound came maybe it's
the wind
maybe the weather may i don't know to be
honest
um but it's kind of a big thing in this
place where it's so peaceful and quiet
to hear them
and they're not always there but
occasionally and today
it's actually now we hear them or i hear
them i don't know if you can
but i think when i turn my camera you
might hear them because the microphone
is pointing in that direction so let's
give it a try to see if you can hear
them as well
yes i know what you're thinking i hear a
lot of bird sounds
yes the birds are also there which is
great
but on the background and i really don't
know if you can hear it you hear this
highway sound which is in a way not
obstructing at all you can easily
communicate with each other
but being in this place kind of in the
middle of nowhere it feels
very out of place to have this highway
sound and like i mentioned it's very
sporadic it's not always there
so we started to first understand a bit
where it comes from
okay so we started with a map so here's
project camp
and here's the highway 1.5 kilometer
distance
and occasionally we hear some sounds
from this area not often
and this is six kilometers away all
right so i'm searching
how far can you hear highway sounds i
live 200 meters away and i can hear the
freeway noise when outside with the wind
in my direction
really 200 meters seems like nothing
depends on the wind
the wind direction will make a
difference okay okay wind seems to be
important
so i'm going to keep an eye on that to
see which direction the wind comes from
and you have some pretty cool
interactive maps on that actually
time of the year is important with the
lots of leaves on trees
okay make sense how do temperature and
wind affect noise
sound waves move faster in hot air okay
also need to visit in a wet day rain
influences
okay and not just the distance but also
the barriers
okay that's a lot of variables hard to
really understand
so i started the spreadsheet to keep
track of them and
three times a day we walk around on the
land
to observe the sound and write down the
things we see
to see if we can see a pattern and it's
actually been quite nice to see the land
this often and really analyzing it while
you walk around
and we notice so far that most sounds
come from the 1.5 kilometer highway
makes sense and we didn't really measure
anything in the cold so
that could still be a reason why we
didn't hear anything in the winter
and we noticed that the base camp is the
loudest place and down in the creek is
the least south
and probably because it's lower in the
land and this made us think that the
landscape must affect
quite a lot as well so let's have a look
at that
to see what's between us and the highway
so
base camp is here and first
there is a lot of vegetation and bushes
and then some
trees here as well but most got burned
like four years ago so mainly young
trees
but there are a few bigger ones as well
also a bunch of houses
i whoops i have to go up a bit here
losing my connection
and here is another field with trees
and then here is the highway
and it's not really busy in fact i've
been driving it a few times and most of
the time is actually not busy
just loud trucks on rush hour get very
noisy
but flying here with the highway down
there i noticed quite a lot of people
live way closer to the highway compared
to us
so you might wonder why is it such a big
problem
i mean the locals are happy with it or
they don't even notice the sound
aren't you exaggerating about the
situation yes
could be but i think what's the
difference is that
as a local you grew up here so you
didn't really choose this place you were
just born just like the place i grew up
i don't know maybe there were highway
sounds maybe not i wasn't really aware
of it
but we really chose choose to come to
this place
of all the places in the world we picked
this one and
it really makes you start thinking like
is this the place i want to be
do i want to be with highway sounds the
rest of my life
and i'm going to invest a lot of time
and resources into this land
is this really the place it's going to
be and i think
those are kind of heavy questions on you
but i guess the rational side of me
would also say
every place probably has its ups and
down sides there's always something you
just got to make it work
true but still it is i don't know maybe
just an excuse to myself
uh so i'm not sure what is the best way
to be honest the only thing i am certain
about is that it's kind of a heavy topic
and i think i had a little bit the same
with the rain when i realized so much
rain would fall here
but actually i could now see a bit more
the upsides of it and grow stuff
and actually when you plant things it's
super nice that the rain comes
but i guess for highways i don't see any
positive
element to it and even looking into
solutions i mean there isn't that much
the best thing i could find was
plan the tree to cover up the sound but
there are already a lot of trees and it
would take 15 years
and apparently another very common
practice is to put a water
fountain to cover up the sound uh
yeah i don't know that's a lot of water
fountains on one land and also seems a
bit strange
but maybe maybe it's worth trying but i
think that's sort of how i convinced
myself
now is that it's a good challenge
because i mean we live one and a half
kilometer away from the highway with a
lot of force
in between if we have this problem it
must be
for way more people or maybe we realize
we just adapt
and uh it's all good as well and once
other people come and we start making
noises ourselves it would
fade away i don't know so i think uh
we're just gonna continue forward and
trying to find solutions to this problem
or
hopefully it goes away and it was just
one
month in spring that it's like this so
yeah
big problem feels very heavy kind of
scared about it but
somewhat positive it will be okay
anyway this brings me to my next point
is
support.projectcomp.com don't click away
i know you always do when this comes
but this is different so we have this
website support.projectcamp.com
where you can support the project by
making a single donation
thank you for everyone doing that or
supporting on patreon
also thank you guys but now today
actually during this video we release
a new section which is called workforce
so it's a specific task that you can
help out with your hands
so it's really to to help us out with a
few problems we have so one
obvious one is i mean the big problem we
don't have a pizza oven we would really
like pizza oven
um but also a sound engineer to look
into the highway sounds or someone that
likes photography
to capture the beauty of the land and
the animals that live here
so i would say have a look on their
website to see if something fits you
and maybe you can come here and
a few weeks ago we also added this
section it's called sponsor big
development
so it's for people that want to
contribute to some some
big amount for a specific thing so it
could be the wood chipper
it could be the renovation of the
kitchen or the workspace
or reforesting the land and we actually
had two big donations from there
one is a new camera which is cool so
that's gonna come
and the other one is a guest house so
the first project camp
guest house is now funded so thank you
very much for that
uh this really pushes the project a lot
so if you have some crypto laying around
make sure to check that page uh
yeah so that was it that was this video
those were the current problems uh i
hope it was not too heavy but i guess
that's how it is
and next video we're gonna do something
fun again not sure yet what
but we'll find something maybe we put
the highway on fire
no